in this video I'm going to be teaching
you how to find your Zen your intercom
whenever you feel overwhelmed in your
life we are really really good at saying
yes to things we're great at taking on
much more than we can actually cope with
from our boss in our relationships
especially with our friendships we're
great at saying yes to loads of things
and before we realize it we're weighed
down with the responsibilities and the
obligations of things that we've taken
on I would like to support you with a
short mindful meditation which will help
you calm your busy brain focus your
energy on something else and feel
relaxed in an instant so please join me
now
gently close your eyes and take a couple
of really nice big deep breaths into
your body and when you're breathing in
imagine that you can breathe into every
single cell in your body wake up the
cells with some oxygen and then begin to
notice where in your body you are
naturally breathing into right now move
your focus your awareness to where in
your body you are naturally breathing
into and rest here become aware of how
the body opens and rises when you're
breathing in and how it softens and
falls down when you're exhaling and stay
focused with your breath noticing any
thoughts arising and allow them to arise
and float away you don't need to engage
with those thoughts stay with your
breathing
stay with your breathing and get a sense
of your physical body get a sense of how
your body feels feel the presence of who
you are whenever you feel distracted or
the mind wandering off gently guide it
back to you and back to your breathing
and rest here rest here with your breath
[Music]
take a couple of nice big deep breaths
in again
[Music]
and then very slowly move your awareness
to your toes give your toes a little
wiggle and gently bring your awareness
back into the room that you're in and
open your eyes I look forward to
teaching you more in the following
videos
[Music]